[Music]
backstroke
i think
what are you planning
well i was planning to retire
but man
is that overrated
what you doing
probing your mind
kind of roomy ain't it
your ability to resist is quite
remarkable general o'neill it's not the
first time i've had a hand in my head
as it were
we tracked them all sir this one is the
last one
you sure
that is after all why we've come why we
had to endure all that singing
get rid of the last bad guy and then
there's cake that's 200 times he stepped
through the gates or not actual missions
to be honest i wouldn't mind one last
jaunt through the old orifice
what
we call it that sometimes don't we
this is new yeah it's always something
isn't it
a crazy idea i'm down with crazy i like
crazy crazy and i are like that
cam likes crazy too that's crazy that's
what i said it's crazy it's nuts it's
wacko
but let's be honest what isn't
yep
just like old
times except i'm here against my will
and
you look like marcel marceau yeah you
know some things change but others stay
the same very good
he's a barber
broke into your house yeah
second week in a row
alarm
i'm thinking dog
you could try locking your front door
so um
i am so sorry
i was just finishing up a lovely brunch
and pillows
no tuna
i take your colonel o'neal
captain samantha carter reporting sir
but of course you go by sam
you don't have to worry major i played
with dolls when i was a kid
gi joe oh major matt mason oh
who made you matt mason astronaut doll
do you have that cool little backpack
that made him fly let's get started
colonel
thank you
for those of you on your first trip
through the gate you should be prepared
for what to expect i've practically
memorized your report from the first
mission i'd like to think i've been
preparing for this all my life
i think what the colonel is saying is
have you ever pulled out of a simulated
bombing run in an f-16 at eight plus g's
yes
well it's way worse than that
by the time you get to the other side
you're frozen stiff
like you've just been through a blizzard
naked that's a result of the compression
your molecules undergo during the
millisecond required for reconstitution
oh here we go another scientist general
please
theoretical astrophysicist
which means which means she is smarter
than you are colonel
especially in matters related to the
stargate
colonel i was studying the gate
technology for two years before daniel
jackson made it work and before you both
went through
i should have gone through then
sir you and your men might as well
accept the fact that i am going through
this time
well with all due respect doctor it is
appropriate to refer to a person by
their rank not their salutation
you should call me captain not doctor
captain carter's assignment to this unit
is not an option it's an order i'm an
air force officer just like you are
colonel
and just because my reproductive organs
are on the inside instead of the outside
doesn't mean i can't handle whatever you
can handle
oh this has nothing to do with you being
a woman
i like women
i've just got a little problem with
scientists
oh colonel i logged over 100 hours in
enemy airspace during the gulf war is
that tough enough for you
are we gonna have to arm wrestle
well you kept the wrong guy cause i
don't know anything about the ship
but you are very attractive
what
hey
big guy i'm i'm i'm flattered really i
am it's just that uh
you're not my type uh
more than a little disturbed that i
might be yours
well no you don't have to do that don't
don't don't don't
don't worry i'm not gonna hurt you
thank god
much
i hope
[Music]
wait wait wait
two obviously give me a minute
not a minute
still not a minute it's here i think the
point of the exercise is to only open
one pot this says treasure is inside
right what makes it the obvious first
choice so over to the gold no back to
the silver then
it's empty
there's nothing i hate more than a
bold-faced lie
okay wouldn't you stop what we're
already trapped in here how much worse
can it get
this is a little keepsake something to
remember you by
this is a priceless artifact this
priceless is the memories we share
well
cute
i hate young goodbyes okay goodbye don't
i even get a hug
daniel
to make this harder than it already is
oh
i can't blame a girl for trying
no i can't
are you ready on you
no give me a warning
i'm going to shoot you
i was thinking more along the lines of
on three
one
two
guys set on three
what
yes daniel he's right here
please hold
daniel jackson
we have caught nothing
we are fishing
banished to oblivion
right
okay uh
thank you if you require assistance i
would be more than happy to return to
the sgc
no thanks i think i can take it from
here
are you certain
give me that
[Music]
if our purpose is to not cause each
other harm
why then are we doing battle
what can i tell you it's boxing
it's fun
come on
come on duke you got to move around a
little bit you got to dance
i do not understand them
are we preparing to dance or to do
battle
duke if you don't move around
you're sitting duck your target
huh like that
i'm sorry you all right i'm fine
well that's why you got to move on
how was that o'neill
it's good that's good
uh
but think about keeping your hands up
is my nose bleeding
you are fine why are you sitting there
if you don't intend to answer any of my
questions because i was requested to by
general hammond
i see and he didn't happen to mention to
you
that part of the interview process
involved actually
saying something
no
all right let's try this
colonel jack o'neill
you must have a tremendous amount of
respect for him
or maybe you don't
only rephrase
uh colonel jack o'neill
is uh your immediate superior
okay maybe not in terms of species
but
all right he's your commanding officer
indeed
good okay good good uh terrific let's
move forward and um is there anything
that you can tell us about him i want to
ask you just let me ask you this where
are you going
so you do your interview with the
documentary crew yet
indeed
yeah i have to admit i can't wait to
hear what everyone else said i did not
say much
really
that is surprising it's usually so hard
to shut you up
i found the entire experience unpleasant
well and this monitors the gate's
massive power consumption required to
generate outgoing wormholes
but interestingly in our study of
off-world dhds we found that our gate
actually draws 10 percent more wattage
than off world gates now that far
exceeds any potential loss due to our
man-made interface
we think it has to do with the way that
the superconductive crystals inside the
gate absorb electrical energy but we're
also trying to demonstrate that the dhds
are somehow producing a purer more
efficient form of power
can we get a shot of the gate spinning
sure it's really cool steam comes out of
it and everything find the eye of raw
before anubis does i mean keep it hide
it destroy whatever it doesn't matter we
don't have much time
hey daniel how you doing long time how
are things in the higher planes
hey jack long time no see how how are
you doing fine just fine then he's in
the back everything oh you know what
kind of weather contingent right right
right right what's his name
um
actually a funny thing happened to me
today um
i'm riding an elevator and an old friend
of mine someone who never calls never
writes just shows up and tells me all
about this very important and apparently
urgent mission that needs my attention
are you going to help or no wait let me
let me tell it it's good you see this
this buddy of mine this pal this chum
has
ascended
to a whole new level of
existence
do you see the irony he's asking for my
help and he's this
great and powerful being
jack we've already been through this i
can't actually do anything
don't don't come in oh
hey there
it's a
long story
[Music]
look all i know is that the place you're
searching right now is not it
then
where is
it
did i just say all i know i do
appreciate that you were the one that
came to see if i was okay that
that means something
i actually no it doesn't
um
we uh we drew straws
i lost
you it would delay their attack until he
arose
perhaps when the warships of your world
attack excuse me did you say the ships
of our world surely you have such
vessels
well we have a number of of
shuttles
these
shuttles
they are a formidable craft
oh yeah
yeah
bad day
[Music]
indeed indeed indeed
indeed
indeed i have not indeed we are trapped
indeed
indeed indeed
indeed
indeed
indeed
indeed she was indeed
indeed indeed
indeed
indeed indeed the sentinel is indeed a
device of great power you are indeed the
token of jaffa legend
these others may indeed be responsible
that was indeed qualified they are
indeed invisible indeed indeed was
indeed a teleportation device indeed
indeed
indeed indeed it
the air is indeed clean
indeed
indeed
indeed you did